fill up our savings is gone look yeah I
know I put it in the stock market now
well the Market's tanking what were you
what were you thinking you told me to no
I didn't yeah you did you texted me
yesterday don't forget to buy the dip
for the party this weekend
oh
chips of course I did
well that's corny
foreign
[Music]
is down you'll hear a chorus of voices
saying you should buy the dip but what
does that mean exactly put simply buying
the dip means investing money into the
stock market when share prices have
recently Fallen since the shares are
essentially on sale you get more bang
for your buck or so the thinking goes
when the market rises again you'll get a
higher return on your investment if the
goal of every stock Trader is to buy low
and sell High then buying the dip makes
total sense imagine for instance that
this is the last 12 months of a blue
chip stock price if you follow Blue Chip
if you manage to buy say a thousand
dollars worth of stock at this point you
would have almost doubled your money in
less than a year but of course nothing
looks easier in hindsight than stock
trading the hard part is knowing when a
stock has hit its lowest point if you
had bought it just a bit earlier you
wouldn't be making nearly as much and if
you waited just a bit longer you would
have missed your chance completely and
that's just the beginning of the dangers
buying the dip relies on a statistical
principle called regression towards the
mean it says that ups and downs are
basically temporary and they will all
average out to reflect a stable
statistical Trend traders who buy the
dip are assuming that if a stock price
Falls sharply it will most likely go
back up again and that is the case much
of the time especially when fluctuations
are based on investor emotional Trends
but sometimes a fall in stock price is
indicative of a fundamental problem in
the company or sector maybe your company
is poorly run and the stock price
deserves to crash instead of buying the
dip you may find yourself tumbling down
a cliff with no bottom in sight despite
these risks you still might be
interested in buying the dip so how
should you go about it most investors
who attempt it will set some portion of
their investment dollars aside in cash
waiting for a stock to fall from a
recent Peak by a certain percentage say
between 10 and 50 percent both ends of
this spectrum carry risk if you set the
percentage too low you may buy in well
before a stock has hit its bottom but
set it too high and you may be waiting
around forever for example Ted here has
about twenty thousand dollars to invest
but he wants to buy the dip so he keeps
three thousand dollars in cash and waits
for one of his favorite stocks to Fall
by 20 finally after 12 months it happens
and Ted picks up 20 more shares than his
money would have bought the week before
the stock Falls a little low lower eek
but then starts regressing toward the
mean even surpassing its recent High
well done Ted you beat the system or did
he Ted may have bought the stock at a
relatively low price but when you look a
little further back in time it doesn't
seem like such a win this stock like
many has a fairly consistent upward
Trend he bought the stock for less than
it cost a week ago but more than it cost
12 months ago if Ted had just gotten all
of his money in at the beginning he'd
have done better overall Ted failed to
factor in the opportunity cost of
waiting to buy the dip most financial
advisors will recommend that if you have
money to invest invest it now cash that
just sits around is worse than wasted
potential it's actually losing value
thanks to inflation there is however
another investment method that confers
some of the benefits of buying the dip
without all the risks it's called dollar
cost averaging it's actually really
simple you just commit to putting the
same percentage of your paycheck into
the stock market every month regardless
of whether it's up or down so for
instance let's say that Marisol here
decides to put two hundred dollars a
month into her favorite stocks no matter
the price that means that when the share
price is inflated she'll buy less of
them and when the share price is low
she'll buy more it's an automatic way of
making sure you're paying what the stock
is really worth historically and for the
vast majority of investors it has a much
better track record than trying to buy
the dip don't get us wrong some people
have had great success in buying the dip
and if you've been waiting for the right
time to start investing it's not a bad
idea to get in when Shares are cheap but
just like a gambler who occasionally
hits the jackpot most people who make a
habit of it will eventually come out
behind study after study has concluded
that accurately timing the market is
virtually impossible disciplined
investors who think long term and don't
try to beat the system almost always
perform better and that's our two cents
history lovers we need to tell you about
a new series from PBS called the bigger
picture hosted by Professor Vincent
Brown it's a show that examines famous
photographs and unpacks the historical
context around them in doing so we
reveal what these photos can tell us
about our history but also how we view
ourselves check the link in the
description and head to the PBS YouTube
channel to see it for yourself and tell
them two cents sent you
thanks to our patrons for keeping two
cents financially healthy click the link
in the description to become a two cents
Patron
if you've ever tried to buy the dip let
us know how it went in the comments
[Music]